So now that we know what ILP is, let's look at an example of computing the ILP
just so we can be on the same page about that. First, we need a program. So
let's say, we have this program. We have already renamed it so
that only the true dependencies remain. So now let's look for
those true dependencies. We write to P10. This instruction doesn't use P10.
Actually, the first one that uses P10 is this one. We write to P6,
nothing uses P6. We write to P5. This one uses P5.
So there is a dependence basically here, and another one here and
then here we produce P4. So we only have really these two true dependencies. So
now, let's look at like what can execute in each cycle. To do that the best way
is to just kind of check off instructions in counter cycles. So
in the first cycle we can do this, this, this, and this because none of these
instructions has an incoming dependencies yet. In the second cycle, okay, this
one cannot be done in the first cycle because it has a dependence from this and
this and that has not been done in the first cycle yet. So
after the first cycle, all of these are done, so now we can do this. So
what we have, what we get is now the ILP is equal to how many instructions, 5,
over how many cycles, 2. We got an ILP of 2.5. Again, we then need to
know what the process looks like. Now, some convenient tricks for
computing the ILP. First, I didn't actually need to rename the program.
If this program had real registers with some anti and output dependencies,
I could just fake renaming by just looking at where the true dependencies are,
and completely ignoring the anpi, anti and output dependencies. Why?
Well, because the renaming would eliminate them anyway.
All that would be left is the true dependency. So you actually,
when you're computing the ILP, don't really need to look at a rename program.
You can do it directly on the program as it was written.
You just need to follow only the true dependencies and
completely ignore the anti and output dependencies. Second, you know,
when checking this off, be mindful to kind of remember how many cycles you're
computing and also what has been done and so on. And then you know,
just be careful also to kind of divide the right thing with the right thing.
So it's 5 instructions over 2 cycles, not the other way around.